You are listening to radio lab radio from W.
N y. S. E. N. P. E. R.
Hey, I'm Chad. I'm Rod. I'm Robert [inaudible].
This is radio lab and our show today is about, uh,
being witnessed to something that's actually not something you really choose to
witness. Yeah. You feel like, should I be seeing this?
This is a story that for me speaks to like what it's like to live in a city.
When you look out the window, we're still,
we're all so jammed together that suddenly you're seeing into the lives of
somebody else through their window and you just kind of fall into it without
even wanting to in this particular tale. It,
what is observed is so surprising.
And so for its tenderness and for its quiet love that we,
it's a rare thing to see.
So we wanted to send it your way from our friends over at Radiotopia,
Nick Vanderkolk and Brendan Baker. So here we go.
This is how their story begins.
So I'd been living in my apartment about 15 years and one evening I walked in
the living room, which has three bay windows,
which faced the gardens in the back and over half a block of gardens and across
a small street there was this bright window that I'd never noticed before,
but it's at the exact eye level of my third floor apartment.
And after awhile I realized that I'd never seen it because there had always been
curtains and so it was always, I think dimly lit.
The curtains were often closed and all of a sudden there's this bright light and
no curtains and it was like a movie screen
[inaudible]
15 years and that window is meant nothing.
I haven't even noticed it. I know it's all I think about it.
There were new tenants and it had always been a living room and now it was
suddenly a bedroom.
And there were these two people in there and they were naked.
This young couple in their twenties they were really lovey dovie and they were
always naked.
That's Diane Wiper who tells the story and she told it to radio reporter Brianna
Breen who produced this piece with Nick and Brendan.
The thing is they pushed their bed so that the head was up against the windows.
So their heads,
you could see the both of their heads lying there so you'd see things that you
just like. They were just shocking.
I just had been there all of this time and suddenly you could see people having
sex really clearly, like, like amazingly clearly.
I had no idea that you could see so well across a such a distance and it was
really uncomfortable.
My husband and I were still adjusting to parenthood and it wasn't the most
romantic time in our, in our lives.
And my son was probably three.
And when your new parents to a toddler,
especially because he sleeps in the bed with us too.
So he's like literally right between us.
The last thing you need is a couple of hotties getting it on across the window,
reminding your husband of everything he's getting.
So to have this really beautiful young woman that was really thin and,
and, and naked all the time, really, you know,
it was very frustrating. And, and, and you know, she had this beautiful tall,
lanky, well-built boyfriends. And so I first, I just,
because I felt like my husband was going to be staring at this naked woman all
the time, I started closing the Living Room curtains,
which is really kind of silly and it made our room really dark and we never
closed those curtains. And so that didn't work.
So I thought about like making a really big sign that said like,
close your curtains or buy curtains.
They didn't even have curtains by curtains. We can see you.
And I thought about going by their building.
I had no idea what their unit was and leaving a note.
And then I started thinking that was really silly and prudish and started
realizing that they were just young and I had to just get over it and live with
it and move on. And so that's what I did.
[inaudible]
we got really used to them and then they became sort of the symbol of what we
used to be, you know,
in our twenties and they were living this really carefree time.
And that's another thing that it was kind of hard not to.
Sometimes when you're an early parenthood you get a little bitter.
I think out some of those freedoms and we'd watch them sleeping till 11 while
we'd been up since five with our toddler and,
and we saw them eating breakfast on the roof together.
So we got used to it and we, we knew we would notice like, oh look,
they got a new, you know, plant in there.
And they became sort of part of our lives, you know,
because they were just always there and never ever bought curtains.
Do you think all the neighbors in your building and the surrounding buildings
also saw this? It's funny.
I think that the way that we are positioned,
because all of the buildings around us are different sizes and our building is
the tallest one on our block.
But it's exactly at the right level to see there.
Their windows.
I have a friend next door and then a friend across the way and all of them have
windows facing the gardens, but all of them are blocked.
And I look at the other windows of the buildings around us and I don't think
anyone has this perfect level view.
The irony is that I'm such a private person and I don't know,
am I supposed to have maybe respected their privacy and just looked away,
but it's impossible because that's the way the chairs face face the window.
I couldn't, I couldn't not see them if I wanted to,
but I guess I could have not gotten the binoculars
[inaudible]
so time went by, and this is maybe a year and a half later, two years later.
And I remember seeing their room and the light was on, but it was empty.
And I thought that was strange cause it was five o'clock in the morning and they
never went anywhere early. And it was like that for like a whole week.
It was just this empty room with the light on.
And I thought that was strange.
They didn't seem to be there as often or maybe it's just she would be there and
he was gone for long periods of time and we just kind of forgot about them,
you know, we just, there were there, they were,
there wasn't as much action going on and they weren't as present and so we just
kind of lived our lives and forgot about them for maybe seven or eight months.
At the end of last year in December,
there was this night when my husband and I separately had both seen this woman
naked sitting in the window,
kind of chubby slump shouldered woman who was just looking down at the street.
And we both thought it was so strange,
she just couldn't figure out who she was and what she was doing and why she was
naked.
And a few nights later there was this young man standing right at the window by
the bed and he was skeletal.
He was so thin and he was bald completely.
And we realized it was the same couple.
They had completely changed
[inaudible]
he was sick. There was something serious wrong with him.
after that, I just watched the window all the time.
Okay, we're going to, we're going to pause it right here. Um, let's just,
we'll be right back. This is Charlie from Brooklyn.
Radiolab is supported in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
hey guys, this is Alison calling from Luxembourg. Radiolab is supported
by rocket mortgage by quicken loans.
Rocket mortgage brings the mortgage process into the 21st century.
With this completely online process,
safely share your bank statements and pay stubs with the touch of a button.
Ditch the paperwork and use your phone or tablet to get approved for purchase or
refinance in minutes.
Get accustomed mortgage solution whenever and wherever you want.
Check out rocket mortgage
today@quickenloansdotcomslashradiolabequalhousinglenderlicensedinallfiftystatesandmlsconsumeraccess.org
number 30 30 hi,
I'm Robert Krulwich. Radiolab is supported by Google and Squarespace.
Make your business official with Google and Squarespace.
When you create a custom domain and a beautiful business website with
Squarespace, you'll receive a free year of business,
email and professional tools from Google.
It's the simplest way to look professional online.
Visit squarespace.com/google to start your free trial.
Use the offer code document for 10% off on your first purchase.
Google and Squarespace. Make it professional. Make it beautiful.
Am Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich. This is radio lab.
Let's get back to our story from Brianna Brene and the folks that love and radio
and Nick Vanderkolk and Brendan Baker.
So we're just going to go back to the room.
See, see what's what we can see through them to
window. Here's Diane wiper.
I just watched the window all the time and he would sit all day.
He was there because I work from home and I would see him all day in the
bedroom, either lying down or sitting at the computer.
And then after a couple of weeks he was just lying down and he was just there
and his bald head would be, um,
up against the pane of glass all the time.
And she would be there and she'd come in and she would bring him things,
but mostly it was just him there by himself.
And sometimes he would have like his knees bent and you could just see how, uh,
skeletal they were. They were just bones.
And sometimes he'd kick off the blankets and he was just lying there naked and
he may C8 it.
And then after awhile he was just always burrowed under the blankets.
I found myself thinking like, well,
maybe he's been through chemo and he's recovering and you know,
he's going through this, um, this sick phase before he gets, well,
because he's so young. He's in it, you know, he's just such a young guy.
And so we had to go to Colorado to see my family for Christmas.
And, um, I worried all the time I was there.
I W I thought about them and I worried that he wasn't going to be there when we
got back. I'd worried all the time about it.
When we got back about 10 days later, um, he was still,
but his head looked so much smaller and um,
and there were a lot of people there. And then,
and then I got out my binoculars, I got my birding binoculars.
I'm not proud of it, but at that point I felt so invested.
It looked like people coming to say goodbye.
And there was this sort of short, um,
blonde Midwestern looking woman who I guessed was his mother.
And then there was this young guy who just kept pacing the halls. You know,
you could just see through our two doorways leading out of this room and you
could just see him go down one side and through the other and then back and
forth and back and forth. And I figured he was the brother
and it looked like the girlfriend's sister was also there. It was just,
it was just a guest looked like her.
I remember there was just this little gathering going on in the living room
right below the neighbors were standing around and having drinks and they had no
idea at all what was going on right upstairs.
I would watch people come and go. Then after awhile,
everyone left except for the girlfriend and the mother. And,
and I spent, and I spent, uh, all that evening,
like sitting vigil in the back of the couch and,
and watching. And,
and I remember the girlfriend lying beside him for a long time on her own,
and she was just stroking his face so tenderly. It was,
it was so much affection that really transcends the kind of young love that you
expect. That's all I could see was the top of his head all that time.
And I remember later seeing her standing by the bed when the mother on the other
side, and they were just all talking and she put a hand on his forehead,
put the back of her hand on his forehead, and then she was wiping at her eyes.
And you could tell that there was this,
that there was this sense that something that it was getting closer,
then I could see this reckoning.
Where's she,
she was wiping at her eyes and touching his forehead and wiping at her eyes.
And [inaudible]
there were candles lit. And,
and this, um,
young woman was on one side and his mother was on the other side
and they just were lying there for a really time and they had their hands just
resting on his chest.
And so I watched it for a long time.
[inaudible]
the mother and the girlfriend were lying on either side of him and you could
tell it was his, this was the end. I thought.
Now all that's left is the girlfriend and the mother and inexplicably me
[inaudible]
me.
Like I'm one of the three people at the deathbed and they lay there for a long
time and then they just got up and they went into the other room
and I realized that must've been the moment.
And all this time, you know, I always had this sense that, you know, they're,
they're gonna break up, they're gonna move out.
Nobody that age stays together very long.
And I had no idea. It was just like this beautiful love story.
[inaudible].
So the next day,
the next day I got up and I went to the window first thing and they were folding
up blankets and stacking them on the bed and I figured that he had been taken
away. And so I was in the kitchen and my husband called because he had,
he knew how obsessed I had gotten with this situation and he said,
there's activity over there.
And I came running and I got my binoculars and I looked and,
and realized that he was still there. He was still on the bed. Um,
his body was still there and it was the coroner.
So the coroner and his assistant came and they had these white plastic gloves on
and they pulled his body to the edge of the bed and onto this white sheet.
And I just remember the, the life lessness of it. It looked so shrunken.
It almost looked like a shrunken rubber proxy of a body,
so incredibly dead.
They wrapped him in the sheet and they zipped him into a vinyl bag and they put
him on this kind of Gurney.
They took the Gurney out and I just had this very strange impulse and I ran in,
threw on my coat,
kind of over my pajamas and ran out to the street and ran to the corner.
And I got there just as they were hauling him out,
they were carrying him out and the girlfriend was there.
She was talking to one of them in the doorway and they loaded him into this van.
And I realized that they didn't know me at all.
Like I had, you know, I had no place to be there.
And they looked at me,
I remembered the coroner's assistant and looking at me like I was sort of like a
rubber Necker on the street, you know, looking at this grizzly scene.
And I realized that that's what I was, I had no place to be there.
And suddenly it all felt so perverse.
And so I went home and I felt very strange about the whole thing.
Um, and I tried to tell myself that, well,
I never want it to be part of their lives. I want it.
I was the one that wanted them to put up curtains.
I wanted them to just shut the intimate stuff out. I,
I was uncomfortable with it. I was the one that wanted out.
And I started remembering all of a sudden the,
when I moved to that apartment so many years ago,
and I was in my mid twenties that I had to share the apartment with a roommate
cause it was too expensive. And my bedroom was in the living room.
And I remember how when I first moved in,
I pushed the head of my bed up against the three bay windows. So,
so that in the morning I could see the sky and I remember that I had no clue.
It never occurred to me that anyone could see me,
that I remember that I felt like whenever I looked out the window,
I never saw anyone. And I never closed my curtains either.
Did you ever find out either of their names? I,
I never have found out their names and I looked through the local obituaries
obsessively for weeks and there was never anyone that fit his description.
There was never anyone young enough or that looked like him. Um,
so no idea.
I walked by their place several times and there's only,
there are only numbers on the mailboxes and the buzzers and there's,
there are no names so I can't look up anything. I don't know. Yeah.
I have no idea who she is. I have no idea who he was,
no idea what he was sick with.
I don't know if I've gotten anything right. Maybe they were married,
but I didn't get wrong. The fact that he died because
I was there, I was there for that because I saw it all.
I think about that a lot. How he chose that he chose to die in that,
in that bed, in that bedroom.
And he didn't choose to go to a hospice or anywhere.
He wanted to be in his bedroom.
All of those long days from the morning when I looked out in the evening,
he was just exactly the same position that was where you wanted to be.
And, uh,
it's where all of the happy times where I guess, and the end times, you know,
just a couple of days after it happened,
she was up on the roof with a friend doing, doing yoga.
And I've watched her lying around a lot.
She went out of town I think for a bit. And um,
she's still there.
I have been watching her recovery and instead of being this young woman,
she looks totally different. She looks so changed.
She just looks like this very, um,
experienced world wary person.
She has a job now that gets up very early,
cause I get up at six and she's already dressed and heads out at like six 15.
And the other night I saw her, uh,
and she was in her bedroom and she, um,
was wearing this baggy t shirt and all the lights were on and,
and she was dancing just dancing around her room.
Okay.
So yeah, I want her,
I want her to move on this,
this young woman that I was so cranky and bitter about, you know. No,
she's now, she's, um,
now I feel so protective and kind of maternal, you know,
if you ran into her like at the corner market or something,
do you think you could ever say anything to her? Yeah,
if I ran into her, I wouldn't say a thing.
What would I say? I've been watching you through your window.
How creepy would that be? Um, yeah,
no way. She doesn't, you know,
sh she doesn't know that.
She doesn't know that there's this person that I don't know,
that's this complete stranger that's out there.
Really rooting for her. You know,
[inaudible]
Diane Webber told her story to radio porter, Brianna Breen,
who produced this with the folks that love and radio,
Nick Vanderkolk and Brendan Baker.
Special thanks to Karen Defin, to Brendan, Brianna, and to nick.
And there are some wonderful stories on their podcast.
You should listen to all of them. It's called love and radio.
You'll find it@loveandradio.org. I'm Chad at boom, rod. I'm running a privilege.
Thanks for listening.